Elon Musk has spelled out numerous doomsday
scenarios for the 7.9 billion people on our
planet: the threat of AI, asteroids, climate change.
Yet he believes one of the greatest risks
to civilization is our population collapsing.
This is what he said at the Wall Street Journal’s
CEO Council Summit in December.
If we don't have more children, civilization
is going to crumble.
Mark my words.
That’s the polar opposite of headlines over
the years that have warned there are too many people.
Stanford biologist Paul Ehrlich wrote in his
1968 best-selling book The Population Bomb:
“In the 1970s, hundreds of millions of people
will starve to death” due to overpopulation
which didn’t happen.
At that time, the world’s population was
growing quickly, increasing by 2.1 per cent
a year on average.
However, it has since slowed down, falling
by half.
To the point where the United Nations predicts
the world’s population will virtually stop
growing by the end of the century, reaching
10.9 billion people by 2100.
Even that estimate is too high for some.
Musk has called it “utter nonsense” and
only the “best case” scenario.
Norwegian academic Jorgan Randers believes
the population will peak at 8 billion in 2040
and decline from there.
The fall in population growth is largely due
to falling fertility rates.
In the year 1800, the average American woman
had seven kids.
By 1900, that dropped to 3.5.
Today, it’s 1.64 children.
That’s below the replacement rate of 2.1
- the level at which births balance deaths.
Meaning not enough babies are born for a generation
to replace itself.
People in richer countries tend to have fewer
kids.
Urbanization has reduced the need for children
to work on farms.
There’s greater access to contraception.
And more women are establishing careers before
starting a family.
However, the birth rate is even low for some
middle-income countries like Brazil, Thailand,
and Chile
Even populous India has dropped below the
replacement level to 2.0 and in cities, it’s
even less.
In fact, the only region with strong population
growth is Africa.
So what will a low birth rate mean?
Fewer people make and consume less stuff.
There will be fewer new homes and schools.
Less demand for services such as restaurants
and shops.
Your standard of living could be impacted
as facilities are cut back.
Mass transit depends on high demand.
Fewer people on buses and in subways will
mean less money to maintain the infrastructure,
which could translate into longer wait times
and fewer routes.
Military strength could decline.
As demographer Lyman Stone once said: “You
need warm bodies to fill the uniforms.”
Some observers predict dire consequences.
Jonathan Last, author of What to Expect When
No One’s Expecting, warns if people in authoritarian
societies have more children than citizens
of liberal democracies, “over the long haul,
those people inherit the earth” leading
to chaos and instability.
At the same time that fertility rates are
falling, people are living longer.
Older people are making up a bigger share
of the total population.
Nearly all areas of the world are experiencing
aging - shown in dark blue.
A small number of workers will be left to
support many retirees.
This is an extreme example of what that could
look like.
It resembles an inverted population pyramid
where there are too few working-age people
supporting too many elderly.
This wild imbalance could cause governments
to raise taxes to cover the burden of caring
for seniors.
In 2019, there were three workingage people
for each elderly person in Europe and North
America.
By 2050, that’s projected to fall below
two.
And in some countries, it already has.
Japan is grappling with a labor shortage by
having robots care for the elderly in some
nursing homes.
To entice more people to have kids, the Japanese
government pays parents 100,000 yen or $876
dollars per baby.
Do it for Denmark.
A tongue-in-cheek campaign by a Danish travel
agency in 2014 urged people to go on more
vacation to get knocked up as stats showed
Danes had more sex on holidays.
In the European Union, the fertility rate
is a mere 1.53 births per woman.
Iran is so worried about its low birth rate
that in 2020, public hospitals and clinics
stopped offering vasectomies and handing out
contraceptives.
China may be the most populous country, but
its birth rate has been plummeting despite
the government scrapping the controversial
one-child policy in 2016.
That got replaced by a two-child policy and
now, families are allowed to have up to three children.
Then there’s the possibility of synthetic
wombs to try to encourage people to have more kids.
Scientists have already successfully grown
a baby sheep in what looks like a jumbo-sized
Ziploc bag.
Dutch researchers believe they are within
ten years of creating artificial wombs to
keep premature babies alive.
Sahil Lavingia, the founder of the e-commerce
platform Gumroad, suggested artificial wombs
would make having kids easier.
Ethereum co-founder Vitalik Buterin added
women’s salaries could increase, as statistics
show their earnings drop significantly after giving birth.
They discussed this in response to Musk’s
tweet about his population concerns.
The SpaceX CEO says he’s trying to practice
what he preaches by having a lot of kids - six
boys so far!
His rocket company wants to build a city on Mars.
However, Musk warns that if there aren’t
enough people on Earth, there definitely won’t
be enough people for the red planet.
Parents are now heavily invested in their
kids, giving them the best shot at a decent life.
Health is wealth.
My sponsor BiOptimizers aims to optimize your
body, mind, and performance by helping you
beat stress, fatigue, and sleep better.
Their magnesium supplement “Magnesium Breakthrough”
is one of the only supplements on the market
that provides magnesium from all seven sources.
Most magnesium supplements fail because they’re
synthetic or use preservatives.
When you get all seven critical forms of magnesium,
your body gets a serious upgrade so you can
relax more, stress less, get deeper sleep,
and simply feel better throughout your day!
To find out more, go to: www.magnesiumbreakthrough.com/newsthink
to get a 10% discount.
Be sure to use the promo code: NEWSTHINK10
at checkout.
You can click my custom link in the description
or pinned comment and try the powerful effects
of magnesium for yourself.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.